Young Eddard Stark: As a boy, even I dreamed
sometimes of being not a Stark of Winterfell,
but a Dayne of Starfall.
Legend has it that the Dornish founder of
House Dayne followed a falling star to where
it hit the ground.
And there, he raised his castle.
A fantastic story, I know, but House Dayne
has a relic to prove it.
Dawn.
The most famous sword in Westeros.Forged from
the fallen star's cold heart, and as strong
and sharp as Valyrian steel.
Many Houses have ancestral swords passed from
father to oldest son, like my own family's
Ice.
But Dawn doesn't pass to the Lord of Starfall
by right.
To wield Dawn, a knight of their House must
first be deemed worthy.
It doesn't matter if he's the lord, a younger
brother, or a distant cousin.
If none are found to be worthy, the blade
stays on the mantle in Starfall until the
next generation.
But Dawn hasn't rested there often.
From House Dayne have risen some of the greatest
warriors in Westeros.
VorianDayne, who was a king and the greatest
knight in Dorne before he was defeated by
Nymeria.
Because of his honor, and his prowess, she
sent him to the Wall in golden fetters and
took his heir as her husband.
Joffrey Dayne, who answered Aegon the Conqueror's
demand to submit by invading Aegon's Seven
Kingdoms and marching an army to the gates
of Oldtown, where Aegon had been crowned.
And the greatest of them all: Ser Arthur Dayne.
The Sword of the Morning.
During the reign of the Mad King, a band of
outlaws calling themselves the Kingswood Brotherhood
terrorized the forest outside of King's Landing.
Every force sent after them either returned
empty-handed or vanished into the woods, never
to be seen again.
The king was furious and dispatched Ser Arthur
of his own Kingsguard to deal with the threat.
Ser Arthur didn't put the villagers to the
question or set fire to the woods to smoke
out the Brotherhood, as other forces had done.
He paid the smallfolk for the food his men
ate, brought their grievances to the King,
even won them the right to take a few of the
King's deer during the autumn.
The forest folk had looked to the outlaws
to defend them.
But Ser Arthur did more for them than the
outlaws could ever hope to do.
When a villager led Ser Arthur and his knights
to the outlaws' secret camp, the Brotherhood,
to their credit, didn't flee.
One of their leaders, the Smiling Knight,
was a madman.
Cruelty and honor jumbled together.
But he didn't know fear.
Not even when Ser Arthur drew Dawn before
him.
Soon, the outlaw's longsword had so many notches
that Ser Arthur stopped to let him fetch a
new one.
The robber knight chose another and then asked
for Dawn.
Ser Arthur replied, "Then you shall have it."
The Smiling Knight never smiled again.
The mad fool.
Dawn is just a sword.
Ser Arthur was the true steel.
Strong, brave, and loyal to a fault.
He would never have aided Rhaegar's abduction
of my sister if his vows hadn't compelled
him.
And though we fought on opposite sides, I
admired him.
When I was younger, I wanted to be him.
Every boy did.
And I killed him.
Not in single combat, but as he was on his
knees, a dagger in his back.
I'll never forget the look in his eyes.
He wasn't angry or betrayed.
He'd done his duty to the last, even though
he found it dishonorable.
And even though he knew what awaited me in
that tower.
Ser Arthur Dayne died the greatest knight
who ever lived.
After Robert's coronation, I returned Dawn
to Starfall.
One day, House Dayne will raise a worthy successor
to Ser Arthur.
Until then, Dawn gathers dust above the fire,
with the dream of every boy in Westeros.
Catelyn Stark: Some houses rise to power through
strength, others through wealth.
House Frey gained its title through cunning.
Centuries ago, its founder looked at a map
and noticed how the Trident spears the Neck,
cutting off the North from the South.
He realized that a river of gold would flow
to the man who owned the right bridge across
the water.
It took the Freys three generations to complete
their forefather's vision: A massive arch
of smooth grey rock, wide enough for two wagons
to pass abreast.
When they were done, they built high curtain
walls, deep moats, and heavy gates to protect
the approaches and put up squat, ugly, formidable
keeps on either bank: the Twins.
Commanding both road and river with arrow
slits, murder holes, and portcullises, the
Twins ensure that no one crosses without begging
the Freys' leave and paying the Freys' toll.
The plan worked.
The family grew rich and powerful, exacting
gold from lords, merchants, and poor farmers.
A good thing too, given the number of Freys
the bridge has to support.
Whatever the case, House Frey does nothing
so well as survive.
When the ironborn conquered and razed the
Riverlands, the Freys hid in their castle.
When Aegon and House Tully swept the ironborn
back to their islands, the Freys hid in their
castle.
When my ancestor demanded their allegiance
as Aegon's new Lord Paramount of the Trident,
the Freys bent the knee from their castle.
Perhaps then we should not have been surprised
when my father, Lord Hoster Tully, called
his banners against the Mad King and Lord
Walder didn't answer.
The Baratheons, Starks, Arryns, and Tullys,
some of the oldest and greatest houses of
Westeros, fought and bled for the cause of
justice while House Frey hid in their castle
and waited.
No doubt if Rhaegar had won at the Trident,
Lord Walder would have given him safe passage
into the North to destroy the rest of my husband's
Northern army for a fair price.
But Rhaegar fell and, lo and behold, the Frey
army appeared to render aid to our already
victorious forces.
Many sniggered that Lord Walder had been waiting
for his army to come of age, having fielded
it out of his own breeches.
My own father named him The Late Lord Frey
to the other lords' amusement.
In many ways, however, Lord Walder was wise.
We had no guarantee of victory and had he
fought with them from the outset and we failed,
he would have lost the bridge his family was
so proud of.
"More Pride Than Honor."
those should be the words of House Frey.
Yet part of me wonders if Lord Walder waited
not out of fear but hope.
That we would be destroyed, leaving him to
assume the my family's place as Lord Paramount
of the Trident.
To buy the respect they have always wanted,
but refused to earn.
Randyll Tarly: Most Houses take wild beasts
for their sigils, calling themselves bears,
lions, or stags as if a cloth banner could
make them so.
That isn't the way of House Tarly.
Our sigil is the huntsman pulling his bow,
and it isn't some idle fancy.
As soon as a son of House Tarly can hold a
spoon, he gets a bow.
As soon as the boy can sit a horse, his father
takes him on a hunt.
They return with a stag, a buck, a boar, a
brace of pheasant, even if it takes days,
even if it takes a week, even if it takes
the boy's whole life.
Horn Hill is ours.
A fitting home for one of the oldest and most
honorable families of the Reach.
Legend has it that Harlon the Hunter and Herndon
of the Horn, two sons of Garth the Greenhand,
raised the castle in the Age of Heroes, and
shared a home and wife for a hundred years.
Most of the Great Houses spout such nonsense
about their origins.
At least my family doesn't claim some long-lost
ancient crown, like the rest of them.
House Tarly breeds soldiers, not kings.
When House Gardener ruled the Reach, we served
them well and loyally.
When House Gardener died, and Aegon gave the
Reach to their stewards, House Tyrell, we
served them well and loyally.
We know our place, even if the Tyrell women
don't.
When Aegon's son faced rebellion from the
Vulture King of Dorne, my ancestor, Savage
Sam Tarly, led the royal forces on a Vulture
Hunt.
Heartsbane, our ancestral Valyrian sword,
and the pride of our House, soon ran red from
point to hilt with rebel blood.
When Robert Baratheon rebelled against Aerys,
I led the Tyrell van and handed him his only
defeat in the war at Ashford.